So everybody
When I never met in person I never met Jordan Peterson in person
But I said to him when we met right before lunch
Something that I said to me by so many people who meet me for the first time. I feel like I know you and
I that is the highest compliment in in effect
I now understand what a compliment that is what I receive it because I never gave it to somebody
before you and
I
I have watched you for hours and listen
To you and read your book and in fact, I didn't just read your book. I heard your book from you
so I want to tell you something without embarrassing you, but I think I
I'd like to you open your heart and your mind and so do I?
When I was very young I realized that God or nature had given me
What I have called a goodness detector
And I knew I always knew when I was in the presence of a good person
Because that's all I really care about. I think brains are wildly overrated
wildly
That's why I think you're not bright if you join Mensa
Why you would want to announce to the world your IQ is so bizarre to me that I
I'm sure there are nice people there, but I I don't understand it, but I always picked up
That and I've and I've always been right
it's a it's a I'm batting a thousand essentially and
When I heard you read your book
the passion comes
from I just
want to help people lead a better life and
It's really it's it's quite overwhelming you you didn't just read that book you
Won't say you sang it but I like that you use music. I'm very much into music, too
so this is the man that I'm
Honored to have this dialogue with because you're out everybody knows you're bright
But I know you're good
So I want them to take that at the outset. I
Was something to say about that good that's good
See I don't think it's true I
mean, this is why I
Got motivated to do what I've been doing and I've been doing what I've been doing for. I would say since about
In one form or another because things take a long time to generate
and one of the things I learned in the early 80s was that
People have a great capacity for evil and I didn't really understand that of
myself
until
The early eighties something like that after meditating on it for a long time and
So I would say
It's not that done I would never claim to be good. I think it's dangerous
But I did become terrified of how terrible I could be
And I mean, I became terrified about how terrible human beings could be and that's one thing but that's easy
It's easy to confuse that with other human beings
You know, it's a different thing to
Understand that it's true of yourself. I
often recommend to my students that they read history as a perpetrator and not as a victim or a hero and
People very seldom do that and it's no wonder
But I would say perhaps that I became terrified enough from learning what I learned that I tried
to
Avoid the pathways that lead people to the dark places that they go
And there's something in that that might approximate good
Yeah, it does approximate good III I I would agree with that
The parallels between
Us are so eerie to me that in my book on happiness, which came out of 99. I
Actually have a chapter on the necessity of having a tragic view of life
and then I hear you speak of light just now this tragic view of life and
Ironically if you don't have that you can't be happy
so it's just another example of
This in that you're getting this message out
if you want to comment on that, please if not
I'll go on I you you you are such an I watch you and you're such an intense listener
I don't know when you're gonna react so
There's this old idea
You know you all know this idea
It's an idea that's
Expressed for example in the classic Disney movie classic Disney movie which I really like
called Pinocchio and you know when Pinocchio is attempting to free himself from
the forces that manipulate him as a puppet and to become an autonomous being
He is required to go to the darkest place
To find the worst
Catastrophes that
Voluntarily and in doing so he rescues his father. That's a very old idea
I
Don't know how old it is it
it's
It's one of the oldest ideas we have in written form and and there's no doubt that in its pre written form
it would be tens of thousands of years older than that and it's a very strange idea that you have to
Journey to the darkest abyss to free the spirit of your father
But there's a reason for it and it has to do with the tragic view of life
Which is that you can't discover
What you're capable of?
Being or withstanding and and those are the same things
Without if you hide away from any of the things about life that are terrible
but true and and and the reason you can't
discover
Who you are?
without doing that is that only necessity will force that out of you and and it I mean that I mean that
From the perspective of learning if you go work in a palliative care award. You'll learn to deal with death
you'll learn that this psychological strategies necessary the
Steps you'll become more informed but it's deeper than that. Even we know now from a biological perspective that
If you put yourself in new situations in new and challenging situations
That new genes turn on in your nervous system and code for new proteins that produce new neurological structures
And so you can't even be what you are fully
biologically unless you expose yourself to everything that you can expose yourself to as you journey through life the old idea of a
Pilgrimage was predicated on on that idea as is walking the
Shark Cathedral the the labyrinth
The idea that you walk the labyrinth in in Chartres and you come to the center is that you traverse every corner of the world
quarter by quarter, and then you come to the center and
The center is the center of the church and it's the center of the crucifixion. It's the center of suffering and
You can't get to what that Center
Signifies without having journeyed everywhere
and so
The tragic view of life is necessary
Because it puts you on the journey that
reveals to yourself who you could be if you were courageous as
courageous as you could be and as truthful as you could be and that's equivalent to discovering 2/3 vivifying your dead father because you
Are an ancient creature in some sense and and perhaps one with a spark of divinity
Inherent in it, but you will never release that
Unless you're willing to go everywhere that you have to go because only necessity will call that out of you
and so you can't be
Happy
You can't be complete without
You can't know what you could withstand. You can't have any proper sense of self-respect
unless you know what you can tolerate and if you avoid
Everything that you have reason to avoid but should nonetheless not avoid you won't know who you are and then you can't live
properly
So you you have said on a number of occasions and in every on every occasion that I have watched you say it
Not a single person in the panel you often talk on panels. Not one person has ever actually reacted to it. I
Totally get it
Nevertheless, it's one of the most important things you regularly say you live as if there is a God
Is that correct?
well people ask me if I believe in God, you know, I just said I'm gonna release a
Podcast about that because I answered that question for about two hours in Australia because people kept asking me about question
which I really don't like I don't like that question and
So I hadn't thought about it for a good while and I tried to figure out why and and then I thought well
He said you believe you see I thought who would have the audacity to
claim
That they believed in God
if
They examined the way they lived
Who would dare say that?
To to believe you think to believe in a Christian
Actually, this is why Nietzsche said there was only ever one Christian and that was Christ
To have the audacity to claim that
means that you live it out fully and
That's an that's an unbearable
Task in some sense. I just debated to Tsavo Asia
About a week ago, although it wasn't really much of a debate
It was it was a strange event
But he said something very brilliant and to me that justified the entire event at least from my perspective
He talked about
Christ's moment of crisis on the cross when he
cried out to God that he had been Forsaken and what Dziedzic said was that what that meant was that
the conditions of human existence are so
tragic
That even God himself in human form
Lost faith for a moment in the goodness of being
and I thought that was a remarkable observation because
Well, if God Himself would lose faith under such conditions
What would you expect from normal human beings?
confronted with what we're confronted by and
To be able to
accept
the structure of existence the suffering that goes along with it and the disappointment and the betray land and -
Nonetheless act properly right to aim it the good
with all your heart right - to dispense with the malevolence and your desire for destruction and revenge and all of that and
to face things courageously and to tell the truth
To speak the truth and to act it out. That's what it means to believe
That's what it means it doesn't it doesn't mean to state it it means to act it out and
Unless you act it out. You should be very careful about claiming it and so I've never been comfortable
saying anything other than I
try to act as if God exists because
god only knows what you'd be if you truly believed I
Mean if you think about it in some sense
that's the central idea in Christianity is that if you were capable of believing, it would be a
transfiguring event a
Truly transfigure event and I know people experience that to one degree or another
But we have no idea what the limit of that is
we have no idea what the possibility is within each person if they lived a life that was
maximally courageous and maximally truthful
You know because maybe you're running that 60 percent or 70 percent or twenty percent and at cross-purposes to yourself
God only knows what you'd be if you believed
and so
Well I act I try to act like I believe
But I'd never claim that I manage it
Because it's too it's it's a lot to manage
properly and you have to be careful about claiming to manage things that you can't manage and so
That's part of the answer to that question. It's a great answer as it happens
Like you to react to something that
Is very operative in my life. I just and if you I always tell people on my radio showing
Totally feel free. He'd say sorry. I really don't don't find that tenable or whatever you however you want to react
Am I my route as an adult to God has been completely circuitous
I have come through the the back door. I
Wrote 25 years ago how I found God at Columbia. I
realized in the 70s at graduate school at Columbia that I was being taught nonsense literally nonsense things that made no sense and
It drove me crazy because they were all bright bright people taught me nonsense
One day walking through Columbia. The only time I ever had I wouldn't say I never had a theophany, but I did have an epiphany
all of a sudden one of the verses from my yeshiva education in Brooklyn, New York the
Cloistered Orthodox world of my childhood and I don't use cloistered and I don't like clustered
But I'm not using it at a pejorative way. I'm just explaining what I had and
All of a sudden one of the verses that we said every morning in kindergarten first grade and second grade
For the first time since second grade came to my brain rashid lafayette other than my wisdom begins with fear of the Lord
Changed my life. There's no wisdom at Columbia because there's no God at Columbia and
That has been
That is one of the ways I knew Oh
Without God. Look what happens without God
look what happens morally intellectually in terms of wisdom, and I my biggest reasons for belief in God are
Watching what happens when people don't
So I'd love to have your reaction
If you cease to believe in God you'll start to believe in anything that
Was the British tested and yet just thank you. Yeah. Well, that's that's a
That's a good that's a good way of looking at it. I
mean if
Catholicism, you know
I've gone through lots of Catholic cathedrals in Europe. And of course, they're stunning creations and but they're
gothic and strange and the doctrine is eerie, and and
Complex and surreal and and and the biblical writings are the same
You think of a book like revelation for example
But I think that the Catholicism that's as sane as people can get
You know
Broadly speaking is that you we need a metaphysic a narrative metaphysic to hold us together
and it has to be
Predicated on something that's transcendent and absolute
And if you lose that then you'll fall for something else
you'll fall for something else or you'll fall for nothing which is which is no better and
I learned that from reading Nietzsche and I learned that from reading Dostoevsky and
This is the problem with the rationalists like Sam Harrison and and and the atheists Dawkins
Now they believe that if we dispensed with our superstitions, we'd all become
Harris and Dawkins
Rational beings
Devoted towards the good
However, we conceptualize that for rational reasons and I don't believe that because I don't believe that we are rational beings fundamentally
I think we're deeply irrational
It's amazing that we can all sit in this room together without tearing ourselves into shreds
And I mean that it's really quite a remarkable thing that all of us who've come from all over
North America can sit here so peacefully and concentrate on a single thing without any tension or trouble
The the improbability of that should not be underestimated
The the unlikelihood that that might be the case
and then the issue of God as well is that there has to be something a
fundamental worth
There is something that you consider a fundamental worth
You know what? I
think that
regard for other people for the consciousness of other people for the conscious being of other people is
Is is in that realm
if you're going to
Have a relationship with yourself if you're going to be able to love someone else if you're going to be able to take care of
Your family and your community
you have to
attribute to human beings and
a value that
Might as well be described as divine given that it has to be the the ultimate value that you hold and
I see it seems to me that it's not unreasonable to associate that value that is
Intrinsic in humanity with something. That's of
Metaphysically that's metaphysically real that's part of the structure of reality
itself and
My sense has been that
it's
It makes
If you watch how people act when they're acting properly
the hypothesis that there is
Divinity within us that reflects
divinity itself is
the only conclusion that makes sense that works and
so I think the evidence I think the evidence suggests that
You know, you said you look look what happens when societies lose their bearings. It's like
Yeah you that's what convinced me to the degree that I became a religious person
I didn't wasn't as if I discovered God it was more like I discovered Satan discovered the devil and certainly believed
that very powerfully
metaphysically or not
You don't have to read that much about what happened in Nazi Germany or what happened in
The Soviet Union or what happened in Mao's China what continues to happen in many places around the world?
to be convinced that there's a great darkness and
it seems to me that if there's a great darkness then there has to be a great light and
the first part of that is
True beyond any hope of refutation and
The second seems to be a logical necessity in the light of the first
It's a powerful line that you you know, I feel so obviously the same I want to talk to you about the darkness
so I've often said
all of my life really that
we
Have a wrong metaphor in calling evil dark because it's it's actually so bright
That people can stare it in the face
the number of Canadian or American
students at the most prestigious universities who could identify Pol Pot or even the Gulag Archipelago
Let alone the Great Leap Forward in China is so small
The knowledge of evil it is now up to over a quarter of kids never heard of Auschwitz
It'll be a half very silly. It will be three quarters in a generation. They don't know evil. I
At Berkeley I was had a dialogue with two leftist students
My last question to them was do you believe people are basically good and they said yes
And I said, it's so demonstrably wrong that belief
That there's only one possible explanation for why you hold it because you live in such a good country
yeah, well, that's the that's the goodness of naivety right and it's something that's that's
Encouraged, you know you encourage that by
Producing safe spaces around people you produce that by sheltering them you want to preserve that childlike?
Innocence but once you're no longer a child, it's not childlike. It's just childish
And that's that's not good to be a 40 year old child and to think that people are fundamentally good. It's it's not
Good is very difficult?
It's by no means the default position. What's the default position entropy?
Catastrophe tragedy malevolence and death that's the default position the good struggles up against that
That's no easy thing to manage to think of that is intrinsic. It's an intrinsic possibility, but it's not something that you
It's not something that
It's not something that you can manifest without faith and
commitment and and the more faith and the more commitment the better and the deeper the better and it's the most
difficult of things to do and and it is
It's appalling to teach people the alternative and I know that speaking I think speak of this clinically
You know
The people who are most prone to post-traumatic stress disorder are naive people
This is well known clinically. It's there's nothing about this. That's it's it's
It's questionable or for unorthodox
If you believe that people are basically good and that the world
rewards
goodness with good in return if that's your fundamental belief that there's not really any such thing as evil and
You encounter someone malevolent, which could be yourself
Well, that's often what happens to people who develop post-traumatic stress disorder, you know, they're there it's very common that people
develop PTSD because they've done something so
incomprehensibly
Morally repugnant that it's damaged them
Psycho physiologically and they cannot recover. It's very common among soldiers
It's not what they saw. Although sometimes it is it's what they did
They have no framework within which to conceptualize it
If you have no theory of evil
if you have no theory of good and evil, if you have no metaphysics and someone malevolent touches you you're done and
so
telling people that
Human beings are basically good and that evil doesn't exist makes them
ripe fruit for the picking by the malevolent and
There's nothing about that that's positive. It's mere
Cowardice masquerading as virtue. It's the devouring mother and from the Freudian perspective. I'll keep you innocent
I'll keep you young and naive and nothing will ever come to harm you it's like precisely the opposite is the case in life
That is why by the way, I truly yep
That is why I
truly believe that a 12 year old at a traditional Christian or a Jewish school is wiser and
More likely to be happy than a secular professor of philosophy who is 50 years old
Just because I knew I went again to yeshiva all the so half the day in Hebrew Jewish studies have today in English secular
Studies I knew at 6 people were not basically good because God said so in Genesis
When he decided to destroy the world because it turned out rotten
so I knew at the earliest possible age people were not basically good and it not only
Affected my felt and show my worldview
It made me happy because then I realized wow
I'm eating good people despite the fact that people about basically good
I really do it but people in my life am I lucky or what?
Yeah. Yeah. Well that that's a that's a really good. That's a really good point because
You see when I said that it was a miracle that we can all sit here peacefully
Like that is how I look at it
I think every day when I walk out into the world and it's not rack and
Runes and flames and floods that it's a bloody miracle. It was I mean it that we hold this together
It's not an easy thing to do and release to think of pace as the default position is a form of deep insanity
like it's it requires work to do to to maintain peace and
You can't be properly grateful
Unless you understand how unlikely it is that?
Well, we're not in the throes of World War 3. We're not still in the depths of World War 2
that the Cold War is mostly over that the economic conditions of people everywhere on the planet are improving at a rate that
could only be described as miraculous and that most things are going in a positive direction if you assume that that's
Normative, then you think well, that's life. But and you have no reason to to be wide-eyed
To have your eyes wide open admiration and gratitude at the fact that
the worst which is frequently manifested itself is not
Knocking at your door at this moment
Because that's the story of humanity and not peace and prosperity
So here we have it and here we should preserve it and here we should spread it
We should do everything we can to live in a manner that makes that most likely and we should do that
Because well you said what did you say fear of God? It's like
Throughout the Old Testament, you know
It's one story after another is that people develop?
Societies and they become arrogant and they wander off the path. And as soon as they wander off the path all hell breaks loose and
If you're fortunate enough to be where all hell isn't breaking loose you should do everything you can to
help ensure that we
Stay the course and walk the straight and narrow path
so I have a
So I have a very deep worry in light of our absolute
Unanimity if you could speak of unanimity among two people, but
we're so consonant in this this is shocking how good things are and
Yet in the United States and I follow Canada a lot but love to speak about America right now in
The United States half at least half of young people think they are living in a rotten society
Sexist intolerant xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist bigoted
That's six herb. That's my acronym for what I just said
this is frightening to me and
I want to know is it frightening to you?
Well
You know, I always try to give the devil his due and
the idea that the West is a
oppressive patriarchy
Characterized by the sins that you just described
It's true
You know, there's if we look through our history personal or political
There's no shortage of things to be appalled by
That's not the question
Exactly, or that's not the issue
The issue is compared to what
No, I was Churchill this time I've got this right
It was Churchill who said that democracy is the worst form of government
except for all the other forms of government and I would say that about our societies is that
There's no we have every reason to be awake and cognizant of our errors
Whether they're political or economic or personal
But
Compared to how it could be
And now it has been in many places and how it is
most
Everywhere in the world and how it was for much of the 20th century
things are so good here that it's absolutely beyond comprehension and
So along with that
Careful awareness of the flaws of the
patriarchy let's say should be an unbelievable gratitude that we could wake up in the morning and
The lights are on and the and the the freeways are running and there's no starvation
Directly facing us and
that our children will live and that the probability that any one of us will die a violent death is negligible and
The thing that bothers me about one of the things that bothers me about the modern
University is the absolute lack of gratitude that characterizes its teachings. It's like
it's half the story, you know, it's like people are oppressed by Nature and
People are oppressed by culture and people are oppressed by their own dark Nate their own dark side
It's an existential reality
But you have to you have to balance that you have to understand that nature has its benevolent
element and that's what's giving you life and you have to be grateful for your culture for everything that it's provided to you and you
have to understand that people can be good as well as
Adversarial and malevolent and you have to be grateful for that and there's damn
there's a there's there's a
There's a damnable shortage of gratitude
in the modern Academy and that's based on a
naivety or a resentment
That's so deep that it's almost in comprehending a naivety and a resentment and a willful blindness to the reality of history
That's so deep that it's almost incomprehensible
So if we ask you it may be you may strike. Whose absurd I'm gonna ask it anyway
Except for technical knowledge like medicine or engineering mathematics
obviously any of the Natural Sciences law
if nobody went if all North Americans
Graduating high school decided I'm not going to college
With the with North America be a better or a worse place
If you took away the STEM fields
Yeah taking away the STEM fields. I
think that universities
Not colleges necessarily. I
Think that universities do more harm than good now that
and I'm very
loath to say that, you know because I've been
Part of the Academy for thirty years and taught it great
institutions
but the
The postmodern collectivist doctrine is so
Psychologically and politically toxic
That I think that
Academia now does more harm than good and
It's not only what it teaches which is the ideology this ungrateful
ideology which denies the existence of the individual
One of the things I might tell you just so you know, this is that
You know that you hear that there are debates about free speech on campus
About who should talk and who shouldn't and people think that's what the debate is about
About who should talk and who shouldn't but that's not what the debate of it is about that
You don't even scraping the surface of the debate if that's what you think. It's about
The debate on campus is about whether or not a human being has the capacity to communicate
intelligibly as an individual or not and
the answer for the postmodernist collective types is that there is no such thing as an individual and
Therefore the very notion of free speech is absurd
Because free speech is predicated on the idea that each of us have something to say, that's ours
That's a consequence of our unique individuality not our group identity or or the multiplicity of our group identities
but something that it's
something that we have that speaks from our spirit that can speak to the spirit of another and produce a
negotiated
peace and
That's what's being debated
That the war that's going on
philosophically or theologically in the campuses is far deeper than you think it no the entire notion of
the reality of the individual which is I think also the entire notion of
The idea that human beings are made in the image of God most fundamentally
That is what's being attacked. It wasn't for nothing that Derrida
called Western culture FAL logo centric phallus for
Masculine logos for logos for truth and courage and centric for centric that was a criticism from his perspective
the idea of the sovereignty of the individual if you don't have the idea of the
Sovereignty of the individual because there's no individual. There's no free. Speech
All you are is an avatar of your group interests, and if I'm not in your group
It's not in my interest to let you speak
There's nothing that we have to say to one another there's nothing but power
it's a Hobbesian nightmare of group against group and
That's the postmodern doctrine
and so
it's to call it appalling is to barely scrape the surface it's it's an assault it is it is truly an
assault on the most fundamental principles by which the West is governed it's not
Surface level philosophy, it goes all the way to the bottom
this is partly why I've been concentrating on religious themes in my
lectures say
Because the argument goes all the way down to first principles
Is
there is
The in is the idea of the sovereignty of the individual
Correct
The Western answer is it's the great discovery of the West the Western answer is that's the most fundamental truth that is
Exactly, what's under assault at the universities? The reason that the collectivist types hate me is
Because I've got their number. I know what they're up to
And I think I think further that
They do not wish to shoulder the unbearable responsibility of being a sovereign individual
So not only is it
And
That accounts for the cowardice and that accounts for the attempt to weaken the spirit of the people that they're teaching
by over protecting them
they're not willing to take on the responsibility and the
Fault has to lie elsewhere
And I think that's a good judge of
someone
Someone's character in general. It's like
Well, the world is in the messy State. Let's say
And the question is whose fault is it an answer is
yours
That's the right answer it's not the patriarchy it's not
Some identifiable group. It's not some structure that's gone wrong, even though those things can go wrong
And that's the other fundamental
truth of the West is
that
things would be a lot better if you were a lot better and you
Have to decide if you're willing to accept that and and you have every reason not to it's a terrible thought
Don't
With Solzhenitsyn, I think this is a paraphrase, but it's close enough
he said that one person who stopped lying could bring down a tyranny and that that
When I first read that I thought that can't possibly be true
and as I understood it, I thought that can't possibly not be true because the only thing that can
break, the spine of a tyranny is the truth and the only person that and the only
Way that the truth can be told is that some individual tells it?
And so it's necessarily the case that tyranny is broken by the truth of the individual
But then the question is well, is it going to be you that's going to do that?
It's no trivial thing, you know people come and tell me
Very frequently and they write me and they say well, you know
I agree with what you say and this terrible thing is happening in my workplace
And you know, I don't know what to do about it
And I don't want you to make my story public and because of the potential for repercussions and I think yeah
Well, I mean, I understand your position. It's no joke -
it's no joke - stand up when when when
When the when the amateur totalitarians are knocking on your office door
But if you don't then sooner sooner than you think it'll be the professional
Totalitarians and then you'll be in this sort of trouble that that unless you've tried to imagine it you can't possibly imagine
so in the minutes remaining
I'm gonna ask you a few personal questions
As I did with the late great Charles Krauthammer at one of our weekend's
Because people like including me just fascinated belicus. So here's one
What was the city in Alberta you grew up in?
Well, it wasn't a city exactly. Okay little town
It's called Fairview
It's about 800 miles north of the American border. So it's a long ways up there. Right so
How often if at all that do you think?
when people stop you at airports and you go around the world lecturing
Jordan Peterson from Fairview
It's hard to believe
Does that happen?
Well, I live I live in a constant state of disbelief
I mean
I'm dead serious about this like I think it's a form of post-traumatic
Post-traumatic shock in some sense. I mean my life in the last three years has been
just a
continuous series of surreal
Impossibilities. I mean on the one hand
I've been involved in a political scandal of some sort
For a good year and a half. It was at least twice a week
And then for the entire three year period it's been at least once a week. It's nonstop and
sometimes it's national and
sometimes it's international but it's
continual and so that's
I'll give you an example. This is a funny little story
my son came over one day about
year-and-a-half ago
And I was having a kind of a rough day because 200 of my colleagues at the University had signed a document
trying to get me fired and
Then they gave it to the Union and and the Union presented it to the administration without even informing me
Even though I'm part of the faculty union, and so I said to my son
Julian
you know 200 of my colleagues today just signed a letter saying that I should be fired and he said oh
Dad, don't don't worry about that. It was only 200
And I thought well that's where we were out, you know, it was like, oh that's not that's nuts
That's a that was a light day
I was ok, you know
And then so there's that and and the fact that it doesn't quit. That's another thing. I can't understand
it's like, you know all this blew up around me around Bill c16 and I thought
well, I've had my 15 minutes or mine then it was like well, I've had my week and then it was like oh I
must have had my month and then
but none of that happened it just kept expanding and expanding and expanding and expanding and expanding and and
every day I wake up and I think well this is gonna come to an end, but it doesn't it just expands and
and that just doesn't seem credible in the least every time I come to an event like this or I mean when I was in
Australia I was speaking to audiences of
5,500 people and it's like how in the world
can you believe that it's like I
you heard what I just said who there who in their right mind would come and listen to someone who just told you what I
told you you know, it's so dark and it's so demanding you wouldn't think that people would
Line for blocks and spend their hard-earned money and and come because it's a like a marital
anniversary
That's what they say. This was our anniversary present to each other. I thank you people you my you're completely out of your mind
And so and then I think to you know that that
That the state of disbelief is necessary and maybe that's an advantage to being older
Because I'm too old to adapt rapidly and this isn't the sort of thing that you should adapt to right
I should be in a constant state of shock disbelief because it keeps my head on straight. I
Don't know what's going on. Exactly. I don't know why it's the case that what I'm saying is so necessary
Apparently but it seems to be and I'm trying to figure out why
But I'm certainly not for a second. I think I take very little for granted
And I mean, I think I take even less for granted than you might think
I told you that I don't take it for granted that you can all sit here peacefully, you know and
And that is how I look at the world is that if it isn't if it isn't burning in rock and runes
then I think it's a bloody miracle and
the fact that things have gone well for me and
That I'm still standing
which is also a miracle of sorts, you know, I mean
There were probably 30 different scandalous
Episodes
that had every
that anyone with any sense would have thought would finish me and
They've all backfired and
that's all so
I
Also don't understand that
It's like I don't understand that I get attacked in new york times and my friends
Call me who are New York Times readers and they say
You you you you've had it this time cuz that was the New York Times, you know
You're not gonna recover from that and I think well, that's probably true
I mean I was expecting it to happen all along and then I wait and then you know
everybody clamors out me and then I
don't respond too much to that and it starts to die away and then all the supporters come out and then there's a
Hundred people who clamor and ten thousand supporters and you know, here's something I can tell you about my life
That's really remarkable
so, you know if you just
Read the press
Well, you'd have all sorts of ideas about me. I mean
You know that I'm a bigot in the broadest possible sense. And so that's you know racist sexist homophobic
Ethnocentric white nationalists. All right
All of those things
And you'd think that there was just nothing but hatred
Although I have been treated well by many journalists
But you you could easily get that sense that like I live in a world
Where I'm surrounded by hatred and that is absolutely not true
it's so not true that that that it's
You know
There are lies and then there are there are there are anti truths then and an anti truth is even worse than a lie
It's like the ultimate form of lie, and that is what my life is like at all
what my life is like is that I
Travel with my wife and wherever we go. And I mean that literally wherever we go
We've been to I don't know how many countries in the last year. It's like I
Don't know how many 30 40 many countries
If I go down the street
nor if I'm in an airport, or if I'm in a cafe or if I'm in a movie theater, or if I'm in a
mechanic's shop
Some person comes up to me every 10 minutes and says I
hope I'm not disturbing you and they're very very polite and they say
I've been listening to your lectures or I've been watching your YouTube videos or I read your book and I was in this dreadful place
six months ago and then they tell me a little bit about
the particulars of that little corner of hell they were in sconce tin and then they say
Well, I've been trying to develop a vision for my life or I've been trying to take more responsibility
Are being trying to be grateful for my job
Mundane though
it may be or I've decided that I'm going to try to put my family together and make peace and
I've really been trying and it's really working and things are way better and
Thank you
And
so
Well, it's so overwhelming to have that happen. Continually. It's very difficult to believe but
It's unbelievably positive
You know, I mean it's if you could imagine if you could ask for what you want today. You could have anything you wanted
You might think
It would be lovely if I could give my life in a manner so that wherever I went in the world
Perfect strangers would come up to me one after the other and tell me that
They're suffering much less
That their families are in better shape
and that their lives are on course because they took
They they took to heart some something that I was communicating
That's as good as it gets as far as I could
I
Had really I don't want to ask anything else
I think this was so powerful and if that didn't prove my instinct is right
Nothing will Georgie Peterson
You are a good man. You are doing a lot of good. I thank God he made you
Thank you